الموضوع يمس المجتمع ويهم الكثير من
العائلات يتطلب منا التعاون والبحث ايضا
والاهم التواصل
بالفعل مشاهدينا بطل حديثنا هو الطفل
والشاب المتوحد اذ كشف اخصائيون واطباء
بان مجتمع البحث الاكاديمي والسرير لا
يزال يعتبر التوحد بشكل عام مرضا ومشكله
يجب حلها في نفس الوقت معظم التمويل
للدراسات يركز على عوامل الخطر الجينيه
البيئيه العلاجه العلاجات وكذلك التدخلات
بدلا من تطوير الخدمات والبرامج لدعم
المصابين بالتوحد تظهر او تظهر اخر دراسات
لجامعات اوروبيه وامريكيه بان الاشخاص
المصابين بالتوحد يريدون المزيد من
التاثير لهم
في الابحاث حول الصحه العقليه والخدمات
والحالات التي يعاني منها المتوحدون
مهمه خاصه لقناه العربيه في محاوله لفهم
التوحد دون البحث في الاسباب او حتى علاجه
متوحد ولكن ليس وحيدا هي حلقه خاصه تكشف
اللحظات الاولى لاكتشاف التوحد وما يرافق
تلك اللحظات من مشاعر صدمه وخيبه ونكران
من قبل الاباء رحله الوصول الى التقبل
ومعرفه وجهات النظر وكيف تغيرت حياتهم
وقيمه الاشياء وكذلك الكلمه النظر الوقت
وحتى الانسان بسبب التوحد رحله مع اناس لا
يعرفون انهم مختلفون وبالتالي لا يفهمون
اختلاف تعاملنا تعاملنا معهم على الرغم
اننا كلنا مختلفون
[موسيقى]
قصيته وبتذكر لمين اعطيناه للناس المرضة
يلي ما عندهم شعر صح
كان
بيبي شو حلو
هالقمر شوفوا ما اجمله بس انا عبالي دلل
وحياتي ما حدا بقى يزعلوا
انا ما بحب زعل حدا ابدا
بحب انبسط
في الاستوديو تنضم الينا زميله ما يحتاح
حتى منتجه في قناه العربيه وكذلك والده
الشاب محمود فاتن مرعشلي اهلا بكما وطبعا
ايضا معنا الشاب ايضا طبعا محمود مرعشلي
اهلا وسهلا
محمود طبعا محمود حجازي اهلا وسهلا
طيب راح نبدا اذا مشاهدينا خلينا نبدا مع
مايا لانه مايا انت اللي بلشتي هاي القصه
طبعا هي القصه موجوده
حوالينا في في المجتمع وفي كل مكان ولكن
انت قررتي انك تتعاطي مع هاي القصه من
زاويه مختلفه هذه المره دائما نسمع عن
التوحد انه اكتئاب سوري اضطراب او حاله
مرضيه للمره الاولى نحن دائما
نبحث كيف ننظر نحن اليهم هاي المره بهذا
الفيلم حاولنا انه
كيف عم ينظروا الينا كيف يفكرون كيف عم
بحسوا لما نحن عم نقرب منهم وعم نحكي معهم
كيف عم بيشوفونا كيف يرون العالم مش نحن
كيف عم نشوفهم انه هم مختلفين نحنا كنا
مختلفين انا وانت مختلفين كمان
فالاختلاف هون منه هو المشكله مش هو
الازمه الازمه ليه نحن عم نعاملهم انه هن
مختلفين طيب خليني اسال محمود انا محمود
مرحبا صباح الخير صباح النور انا فاشل اني
انا اعزف احلى معزوفه انت تعلمتها وكيف
تعلمت الموسيقى
لحاله كيف لحالك
ضائع عقيده
تعلم تعلمت لحالك هل هل والدتك سعادتك انه
جابت لك احد يعلمك ايضا العازف محمود الى
لحالي
سمعت انه انت بتحب عمر خيرت له
كونسرتو حفله كبير وقررت انه انت بدك
تتعلم من مقطوعاته مزبوط شو المقطوعه اللي
عم تتعلم على
عمر ام احمد الله صعبه ولا ولا عم
بتلاقيها سهله عملاقيها سهله
طيب انا انا بدي ايضا ان اذهب الى فاتن
فاتن
لما اكتشفتي حاله محمود كيف تعاملتي اولا
مع نفسك وبعدين مع المحيط القريب منك
سؤال جدا حلو مهم رح اختصره انه نحن
كاهالي يجب اللجوء الى اخصائيين للمساعده
لانه نحن لحالنا ما رح نقدر نطلع من
الموضوع قد ما كنا قوايا بحاجه للدعم
وبهالمناسبه انا عندي رساله صغيره
كاخصائيه هلا مش كام محمود كاخصائيه في
السلوك
للتقبل والالتزام ست فاتن خلينا بس نفسر
بانه انت بعد ما تم تشخيص محمود بالتوحد
قررتي انك حتى تدخل هذا المجال بشكل
احتراف احترافي دراستي اذا بس يعني
تحليل سلوك تطبيقي وتحت مظله تحليل السلوك
التطبيقي درست
العلاج السلوكي للتقبل والالتزام اليوم
عنا صار في العالم العربي علاج مثل ما هو
الخاص
للتقبل والالتزام فاليوم نحن
من حقهم علينا كاخص محمود وكل الاشخاص من
اصحاب الهمم من حقهم علينا كاخصائيين انه
نحن نشتغل معهم بضمير مش بتجاره بكون على
طول ابديتد وعلى طول مطلعين على اخر
التطورات والابحاث اللي ممكن تساعدهم
ومثبته علميا ومن حقهن علينا كاهلي انه
نحن نتقبلهم في العالم العربي وفي محيطنا
دائما عندنا النكران ابني ما في شيء هل
هذا يساعده لانه انا اسمع انه بعد سن معين
قد لا يفيد العلاج
التدخل المبكر هو
يعني
كالسحر كلما تدخلنا مبكر اكثر كلما راينا
نتيجه اجمل واسرع على على الشخص مشان هيك
حتى لو فاتوا بفتره النكران
مش بلشوا راسا في العلاج انتم يعني افصلوا
نفسكم عن الطفل انتم لازم تتعالجوا حالكم
نفسيا لانه هو في برو في وقت ولكن هذا
الوقت هو عم بيخسروا
باشروا في العلاج
وخلال علاج طفل انتم بلشوا في العلاج مع
نفسكم مش مقبول بقى نخجل منهم نقطه مهمه
كتير لانه حتى الناس اللي المربيين او
اللي بيرعوا اي شخص عنده
احتياجات خاصه هو نفسه بحاجه رعايه نفسيه
ودهنيه كمان خليني ارجع لمايا مايا كيف
غيرتك هاي التجربه او او كيف اثرت فيك أنا
طيب انا ما بحب احكي كتير عن هذا الموضوع
بس انا عندي طفل توحد
لقيت
لقيتو بالاطفال لقيتها بهذا الفيلم يلي
انا ما كنت صاحبه الفكره الفيلم او الحلقه
من مهامها خاصه صاحب الفكره هو الزميلي
شريف المغازي وبدات بتنفيذ الحلقه زميلتي
احلام اليعقوب ما بعدها ذلك حدث اشياء
يعني بيناتنا زملاء نحن وسلمتني الحلقه
واشتغلت مع شريف كنت بالاول
يعني اكثر ايجابيه مبسوطه اكثر اني اشوف
هيدي الاطفال اكثر وحسيت حالي انه انا
قويه لانه احنا في محل من المحلات بنحس
حالنا عنا قوه خارقه بس بلشت التقي بمحمود
والاطفال الثانيين تفضل لانه في احنا
وقتنا انتهى للاسف لكن الامهات
قبل ما ننهي بس سؤال واحد محمود انت شو
بتحب تصير لما تكبر بتحب تصير عازف مثل
عمر خيرات ولا بتحب ترسم صراع
مثل عمر خيرت وتعز مسرح هيك كبير ويكون في
ناس عم تتفرج عليك ان شاء الله
انا رح اكون اول حدا بتفرج عليك انا اللي
راح تذكره ههه
شكرا جزيلا فاتن محمود شكرا جزيلا
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات
والتقاليد والاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات